so it's been a few days since I updated
you on this new initiative to expand the
show the gist of the expansion is that
what we would like to do to really
further solidify staffing on the program
and also allow us to continue producing
shows during vacations so that instead
of periods during which there are no new
shows we can kind of have a rotating
staff to continue production I want to
add a new producer position to the David
Pakman show and what we also want to do
is reduce the amount of commercials in
each episode which will give us more
time during our hour sort of broadcast
time clock to do additional political
content and in order to do that the goal
has been to add 500 new paid supporters
of the show be it through membership
patreon or YouTube sponsorship and I am
very pleased to tell you that as of this
morning we passed a hundred and fifty
new supporter marks so the goal is 500
new supporters and we are now beyond 150
new financial supporters and that means
we are inching closer and closer and I
hope that we make this a reality soon
and I do think that that would also
really kind of improve the show's
standing with our affiliate stations
affiliate stations understand that we're
a small operation so that when there are
vacations there are no new shows and
even if they understand it they don't
like it and they often say David it
would be great if you figured out a way
where you could be on vacation and there
could be a guest host and then you could
come back and you could have a fill-in
producer so that everybody can still get
their breaks but you can continue
producing and that's exactly the goal so
there are three ways that you can
participate all three count equally
towards the goal of 500 new financial
supporters number one is membership
membership is the old tried-and-true
method of supporting the show dating
back to 2010 you can go to david
pakman.com slash membership monthly and
yearly memberships are available if you
want a discount off of your membership
you can use the coupon code vote soon 18
that will save you 40 percent you get
all the great member benefits including
the daily bonus show you get the
commercial free audio stream the
commercial free video stream of the show
that's membership very very
straightforward second method that will
will help get us to 500 new supporters
is patreon doesn't matter how much you
have to contribute even if it's $1 a
month which is the minimum on patreon it
still counts as one of those 500 new
supporters you can go to
patreon.com/scishow and hit the orange
become a patron button also great perks
on patreon at the $5 a month level you
get the bonus show and at the $10 a
month level you get not only the bonus
show but also the commercial free video
show every single day and a third option
this is something new and it's perfectly
fine as well it counts just as much
towards 500 new supporters we're part of
a youtube beta for what's called YouTube
sponsorship YouTube sponsorship is $4.99
a month it has its own set of benefits
including a sponsor only icon next to
your name in comment and chat posts as
well as sponsors only posts on YouTube
you just hit the sponsor button on
either the YouTube channel home page or
on any internal video page you can sign
up it doesn't show up a hundred percent
of the time since in beta and YouTube is
sort of testing the algorithm it doesn't
always show it to every visitor to our
channel but it'll eventually be there
and over 150 on the way to 500 and
there's lots of other things I would
also love to do by the way when we get
this new producer there's three to five
new platforms that the program has been
invited to participate in that we just
don't have the capacity right now to
post our content to I'd love to be
putting content on there were sort of
maxed out with current staffing so this
is really this this is a big deal adding
this position will allow us to do about
25 more shows a year it will extend each
show on a daily basis by about 10%
because of the advertisers that we will
pull off of the broadcast show and it
will basically open up the door for new
opportunities new platforms thing that
haven't even told you about because
we don't yet have the staff bandwidth to
do that so let's make it happen
membership patreon YouTube sponsorship
I'll have an update maybe at the end of
the week